welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit w WC mu edu slash
multimedia
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
Raisa Hines
hello CMU and pit and I guess Chatham
and carlo and everyone hmm it's good to
be back in Pittsburgh I am a CMU trustee
it's even greater than being great to be
it's burgers to have Michelle Obama our
next first lady of the united states
elections are always special to me I
grew up in a place where there were no
election days the mozambique of my
childhood in East Africa was ruled by a
right-wing dictatorship in Portugal old
colonial days my father was 71 years old
when he voted for the first time I never
cast a ballot until I became a citizen
of the United States and an American
citizen of course but when I did it was
for a young man who spent years teaching
me about the needs of pennsylvania's
working families and the good that our
government can do for them my late
husband Senator John Heinz
and some of you might know he taught at
CMU until he was elected a member of
Congress in 1971 he believed firmly as
all dreamers hard-working optimists do
that when you care about people and you
put the interests ahead of politics you
can really make a difference and in 2004
I was back here again with my husband
senator john kerry in in a presidential
campaign that reminded me how precious a
vote can be pennsylvania voted for both
of these good men and this election I
hope Pennsylvania will join me in
crafting a ballot for another great and
good man senator barack obama
for a long time yes we can for a long
time the cynics said that Barack Obama
should should have waited to run for
president and you've heard him talk
about the urgency of now well they said
he hadn't been in Washington long enough
they said the cynics have spoken now
it's time for people to decide and its
people like us who can lend our voices
to a movement to restore people's faith
in government and in the hope of America
itself and on April 22nd Pennsylvania
can make history and take decisive step
towards making Barack Obama the next
president of the United States
you know people some people legitimately
think that he hasn't been around enough
he doesn't know enough he hasn't
legislated enough and you know I think
in our society we tend to be so
numerical everything is in inches or in
dollars or whatever and no one counts
the eight years he was in the state
Senate in Illinois the years he was in
south side of Chicago working as a
community organizer
and I know from running philanthropies
and from doing a lot of on the ground
work here in Pennsylvania and elsewhere
that the most important things are not
so much just what you know is what you
do with what you know and he did what he
knew and he could have been a big top
Wall Street lawyer or anything having
been head of harvard law review first
african-american but he didn't he went
to the south side of Chicago to work
with the unemployed steel workers etc he
knows firsthand firsthand the
devastation and despair of a global
economy that is not properly what's not
fair or regulated he knows firsthand how
important it can be to people overcoming
setbacks and getting their lives in the
neighborhoods on back on track and he
knows this because he's helped give
other people hope it's not just an idea
it's real and he'll give us hope when
he's our president barack and michelle
have known something that I learned
decades ago marching against apartheid
when I was at University in South Africa
in the 1950s 10 years before it's big
martyrs in America there is a value in
taking a stand whether or not anybody
may be noticing it and whether or not it
is a risky thing to do and from Iraq to
the environment to fighting for the
middle class Barack Obama knows how to
take a stand and he knows how to bring
us together for all things I admire
about Barack Obama for all the things
he's been right about I can see no
better example of his good judgment when
choosing such a smart independent
beautiful honest and caring and yet
strong woman to become his partner in
life
your mother of their two precious
daughters sasha and malia over the past
months Michelle and I become good
friends mostly through the blackberries
because you know she's not busy neither
am i but I'm honored to introduce it to
all of you Michelle and Barack have many
things in common but one stands out with
so much smarts and so much opportunity
they could have gone anywhere but each
in their own way decided to go to the
places where they could help people the
most other successful law Korean
Michelle dedicated herself to public
service in 1993 she was a founding
executive director of a leadership
training program to help young adults
develop skills for career in public
service later at the University of
Chicago Michelle developed the
university's first community service
program and as an executive at the
Medical Center she built the business
diversity program Michelle's warmth and
honesty has inspired Americans from
every religion and race political party
and generations to dream of the day that
Barack Obama is sworn in as president
and on april twenty second you can help
us bring closer to that dream my friends
please welcome the next first lady of
the united states
so I hear this is a tough Mike it's kind
of wobbly look what's going down Mike's
going down how are you guys doing
we have here Oh plan B here we go yeah
there we go are we ready for some
excitement not with the mic I am so
honored to be here i want to thank a few
people first the carnegie mellon
administration and the staff who made it
possible for this event to take place
here thank you guys and also to students
for Obama wearing my students for Obama
yes we can
and of course last but not least the
woman who introduced me to raise the
Hinds who has been such an exceptional
mentor to me personally you know they're
not that many people who have gone
through this who you can reach out to
and say what is this going to be like
and she has been so generous with her
time with her emotions she is a true
passionate advocate for the right things
for this country and I want us to give
her another round of applause for Teresa
Heinz
so
I don't know if you've been following
this but my husband Barack Obama is
running for president of the United
States
still running
and it has been an amazing year this
year has been so much more than I would
have ever imagined it is required
patience sacrificed in sacrifice
dedication but when we first started
this thing more than a year ago we
didn't know what to expect in February
Barack announced his candidacy in
springfield illinois in front of the
steps of the old state capitol and it
was freezing cold because we live in
Chicago Illinois you may know something
about bitter cold it was about 20 below
and the event was outside and I said no
one's coming because it is too cold that
was the first time in a long time that
had been wrong but sixteen thousand
people showed up for his announcement
16,000 people
and the enthusiasm has not died down we
were ecstatic it was an amazing
inspirational day but after that day
everybody said this race is over it said
there was no way that Barack Obama could
win there was a candidate that was
inevitable and we said well really it's
over that's it we didn't have chance to
talk to anybody nobody voted we hadn't
raised any money but all the pundits
said it is over they said there were
several things that needed to happen to
demonstrate a strong candidacy and of
course Barack could do none of them the
first was raising money they said that
the true test of a strong candidate was
the ability to raise money and they said
there was no way that a guy named Barack
Obama was going to be able to raise the
kind of money to match the financial
wealth and might of an inevitable
candidate but see what they didn't
anticipate was the way that Barack was
going to go about raising money you know
he relied on regular folks
his philosophy was that $23 was just as
important as 23 hundred dollars if you
voted and got engaged so he built a
financial organization that reached out
to regular folks and folks were right in
twenty dollar fifty dollar a hundred
dollar checks we amassed millions we
have now surpassed a million donors
unprecedented
so as a result of people like you Barack
not only was able to compete financially
but surpassed every expectation but then
after he raised the money what happened
they said well money's not important
everybody's going to raise a lot of
money so that's no longer important what
was the true test of a strong candidacy
was who could build an organization
because they said no they said not
Barack they said there was no way that
this guy Barack Obama maybe he could
raise a little money but he certainly
couldn't build the kind of political
organization to outmatch a political
dynasty that had been building
relationships around this country for
decades but then what did barack do we
approach that differently because he
said you know what I'm going to reach
out once again to regular folks and his
campaign attracted thousands of folks
who had never been engaged in this
process before who didn't find a reason
to be involved a lot of young people but
let me tell you it was folks from all
walks of life that came to volunteer and
we built in the early States some of the
strongest political organizations that
folks had ever seen so he built it but
then after he built it they said well
organizations not important everybody
can build an organization the true test
of a candidate was whether they could
win Iowa member Iowa
Iowa was the test because they said Iowa
was different because Iowa was a caucus
and with caucuses you've got to go into
the state and they get to know the
candidates up close and personal it's
different Iowans take this process
cereal seriously and we found that to be
the case we went in Iowa we spent months
in Iowa I have been to every county in
that state and it has been a joy because
the folks in Iowa do take this process
seriously we met in churches and go got
somebody from Iowa we love Iowa we were
in open-air barns in people's kitchens I
mean these were the days we were just
talking about reminiscing about those
days in Iowa where we would sit down
with 50 people in 20 people and talk for
hours the folks in Iowa did get to know
every candidate up close and personal
and you know what they decided they
decided that Barack Obama was their
choice
now we were excited too we were excited
about that too because Iowa was the big
test Barack won Iowa overwhelmingly but
then what happened they said I was not
important Iowa's not important because
it's just a caucus and caucuses are
different they don't count as much I was
there that's what they said they said
that what this was now was a national
race because he Barack was down in the
national polls back then down by double
digits and they said that there was no
way that Barack Obama could narrow a
double-digit lead there's no way until
he started doing it and then the polls
started narrowing and then we roll into
New Hampshire and New Hampshire was
supposed to be his opponents firewall he
was supposed to get killed in New
Hampshire because his opponent had been
building relationships in that state
well we didn't win the state we only
lost narrowly by about two or three
percentage points but walked away with
just as many delegates we consider that
a huge victory and then we came to South
Carolina Oh South Carolina
we were excited too until they said that
South Carolina doesn't count because
Barack was supposed to win South
Carolina we were like really it's not
gonna count no but what they didn't
count on was the margin of victory they
didn't realize that Barack was going to
win South Carolina lineup by such an
overwhelming margin and that he didn't
just win the black vote in South
Carolina he won every county in that
state except for two so that was hard to
spin so where are we now we're in this
place where Barack has one more pledged
delegates he's one more the popular vote
he's raised more money he's one more
states he's won in all kinds of states
he's one in red states and big states
and small states and blue states in
swing states he's won the black vote the
white vote he's won among women and
young people he is a mast victories so
diverse I ask yourselves when was the
last time that you've seen a candidate
who could pull together wins in places
like Utah and then in Virginia and then
go up to Alaska and then go down to
Louisiana and back up to Maine and
Illinois
when was the last time we've seen
somebody who can pull together that kind
of a diverse coalition oh and yes he did
win the Texas caucuses by the way
so Barack has done what everybody said
he couldn't do over a year ago this has
been an amazing year and we've learned a
few things this year we've learned a
couple of things first of all we've
learned that the American people are
hungry for change hungry for something
different and some of this is about
Barack but a lot of it is about people
being tired of the way things have been
and folks are engaged in a way they have
not been before people have been lining
up to attend political rally standing
out in the cold with their kids on their
shoulders people are watching CNN and
MSNBC those stations haven't seen such
high ratings people are engaged folks
are sitting around the TV with their
five year olds watching presidential
debates folks are engaged people are
talking about delegates pledged
delegates super-delegates when was the
last time anybody knew there were even
any delegates this is this is something
new that's going on and it is a very
good thing no matter what the outcome is
this level of engagement in the
political process people feeling like
they can have a stake young people
coming out of the shadows and saying we
can own a part of our democracy
that is a good thing and we should all
be proud of that we should all be proud
of that but we've also learned something
else this year we've learned that we are
still living at a time in a nation where
the bar is set and I talk about this all
the time the bar is set they say you
know if you can get here you'll be okay
you can do this thing you're good and
then you work hard you struggle you
reach you get to the bar you're right
there you're about to grab onto the bar
thinking that you've arrived and what
happens they move the bar snatch the bar
right out from under you and that's kind
of what's been going on in this race
raise a little money not good enough
build an organization not good enough
the winds that you have never count you
always have to do a little bit more but
the irony is that that's what's going on
for regular folks in this country the
truth of the American experience today
for many regular folks is that folks are
trying to reach a bar that just keeps
moving and the problem is that when you
live in a nation where the bar is always
shifting and moving and you don't know
whether the work that you put in is
going to lead to the outcome that you
thought you get is that it makes people
feel isolated because folks are
struggling so hard every day and their
struggles are not amounting to what they
hoped would happen so you start feeling
isolated and lonely and it is easy to be
divided when you are in a country that
is struggling to reach a never moving
and shifting bar you feel like your pain
and struggle is all your own that you
are alone in your failures
so it's easy to be divided and it is
also easy to be a pathetic because you
feel like you know what I am working so
hard and can't get ahead that why bother
what's voting going to do you don't
trust that your government can do
anything so people fold their arms and
disgust and say you know what that's
somebody else's problem I don't have
time to vote because I'm too busy trying
to chase an ever moving bar so people
don't engage and when you live in a
country where the bar is moving and
shifting on you then it is so easy to be
guided by fear because when your world
isn't right when you're trying to do
everything in your power to make it
right and it doesn't happen all you have
is fear fear of other people who are
threat to you and that's where we are
and the problem with being in a country
that is guided by fear is that it cuts
us off from one another it cuts us off
from one another in our own
neighborhoods and our own families and
our communities and it has certainly cut
us off from the rest of the world the
problem with fear is that it creates
this veil of impossibility and we spend
more time in this country talking about
what we can't do what can't change what
won't work and we pass that belief
system on to our children so we're
raising a generation of young people who
are insular and timid and many of them
don't try because we already told them
why they can't do it and see I don't
want that for my girls you know I got
these beautiful little girls Malia and
Sasha and like many of you they are our
light and my view is that in 2008 with
all that we have overcome we deserve to
hand those children the best
we should be living in a time when all
children in this country no matter what
their race their neighborhood their
gender their parents political party all
our children should be able to dream big
huge gigantic dreams and know that they
are going to have the local support and
resources of this entire nation behind
them every step of the way that's where
we should be right now but we're not
there and we do it we're not there
because we are still struggling to catch
that bar and you lose focus when you're
trying to catch a shifting and moving
bar and I know this because of how I
grew up I talk about this everywhere I
go I talk about how I view the world the
lens through which people like me and
Barack see the world it comes from our
up green because I don't care how many
news covers I'm on or stump speeches I
give or how many times Barack is in
front of big crowds deep down inside we
are working class kids and we view the
world through that lens and when I look
at the life that I lived growing up not
so long ago it has changed the life I
was able to have that my family was able
to provide for me is no longer possible
my father was a blue-collar City worker
in Chicago they did not go to college
but see what my father was able to do on
that simple City salary he could raise a
family of four my mother stayed home
because you could send your kids to the
neighborhood public schools around the
corner and know that they get a good
education so I tell people when you look
at me don't see just the next first lady
of the united states i want people to
see what an investment in public
education can look like
we need to be reminded of why public
education is critical because I wouldn't
be here if it weren't for those solid
neighborhood schools around the corner
with good teachers we didn't have a
whole lot of resources but we had
parents who cared we had art and music
and Jim there was nothing miraculous
about my upbringing there were no
miracles happening in my household all I
saw every day was hard work and
sacrifice see because when you grow up
with parents who are willing to put all
their dreams aside to let you achieve a
little bit more you see them getting up
and going to work every day the jobs
that they don't love my father a man
with a disability went from being a
swimmer a boxer serving into the
military but because of him as he
couldn't walk without the assistance of
a cane my father didn't complain didn't
show disappointment he got up and went
to work every single day that's what I
saw and what I now know as an adult with
my own children is just how much of a
struggle that was but you know what my
father had was the ability to get up and
go to a job he took pride in the fact
that he could support his family my
father like most Americans in this
country didn't want much my father
wasn't asking for much my father didn't
mind having a bar that was high he
didn't mind working hard he just wanted
the bar to be still he wanted fair he
wanted opportunity and most Americans in
this country all they want to know is if
they get up and go to work every day
that they'll earn enough to take care of
their family that they'll earn enough to
pay their bills
most Americans want to know that they
can send their kids to some decent
public schools in their community and
ensure that they'll get a decent
education maybe go to college but at
least be prepared for a job folks want
to know that if they get sick they won't
go bankrupt and they want to know that
after a lifetime of hard work and
sacrifice that one day they can retire
with a little respect and dignity that's
all that most Americans want they want
the bar still but see we're living in a
time with a shifting and moving and bar
that that little dream of life that my
father provided me is gone for regular
folks and this has been true throughout
Democratic and Republican
administrations that's where the hunger
comes from because we're not there yet
we all know this we're living this the
jobs that my father had those blue
collar jobs don't exist they're
dwindling all over this country I don't
care where I go people are begging for
jobs and if you're lucky enough to have
a job nine times out of ten salaries not
keeping up with the cost of living so
people are working harder and harder for
less and less as costs are going up food
gas rinse people cannot make it and
they're working just as hard and I don't
know how single parents do it there are
millions of them all over this country
and you know what I know single parents
love their kids too and they are doing
their best feeling every day like
they're failing because they don't
realize how much that bar is moving on
them going to two and three jobs coming
home trying to cook a good meal keeping
up with kids homework it is impossible
but yet they're trying still and feeling
depressed and education it is not what
it needs to be everybody in this country
knows that No Child Left Behind is
strangling the life
out of our education systems teachers
don't have the resources or the
flexibility to teach parents don't know
whether their kids are getting the
preparation that they need and we all
know that the measure of a child's
success cannot be by a couple of tests
because if that were the case I wouldn't
be here so now parents have that to
worry about on top of whether they have
enough are there kids being prepared can
they go to college in college you all
know what a dream college has become and
there are thousands millions of young
people like me and Barack who did
everything that was asked of them many
met and have surpassed the bar took
every tests prepared applied got in to
the College of their choice only to look
at the cost look at their family's
income and say there's no way I can do
this even though I am ready and prepared
I can't afford it so they don't go every
for every student here there are many
many more of you at home who are not
here because you couldn't afford it not
because you weren't ready and then there
are those of us who take on the loan
debt we are here because we take out
loans that was me and Barack
just a few years ago we were still in
debt for our college education it was
the biggest bill we had bigger than our
mortgage can see we went to those good
schools and I'm still waiting for
barracks trust fund to show up like you
sure that I heard about Dick Cheney and
I thought well maybe we got some coming
from cousin Cheney but alas my husband
was broke but we did what we thought we
were supposed to do we got good
education we left corporate America and
with every step we make bring our skills
back to our community we made less money
my mother laughed too she's like what
are you all doing so by the time we
should have been saving for our own kids
college we found that we were still in
debt paying down our own education
imagine a president of the United States
who's just few years outside of paying
down student loans we've never seen that
before
we have never seen that before but that
would be Barack the only reason we're
not in debt today is because Barack
wrote two best-selling books I say it
was like Jack and his magic beans he's
like look honey I'm gonna write these
books and we'll be fine i'm like yeah
sure right but he did it and i think all
of you own for buying that book but
there are millions of young couples like
me and Barack with their MBAs and mphs
and ma s and M SWS and QRS TUV s all
ready to do the right thing but they're
finding that they can't say for their
own kids college because they haven't
paid down their debt that bar is moving
and shifting and the same thing is
happening with health care we are a
nation in debt not because people are
buying big fancy cars but because
somebody got sick and see we were told
that if you have a job and little health
care which millions do not then you'd be
okay but now we're finding that
deductible xand premiums are so high
that most Americans that I meet are
praying that they don't get sick because
they will be in financial ruin I don't
care wherever I go there are more
Americans who do not know how they'll
handle a health care crisis and they are
gambling that things don't turn out
badly and these are folks getting up and
going to work every day with children
and the same thing is true for our
seniors the bars shifting and moving see
because those folks all of us who have
those people in our lives who have given
up everything for us to be standing here
who have worked their fingers to the
bone only hoping that one day they could
enjoy the fruits of their labor and
sacrifice put their feet up maybe have a
vacation maybe work on a hobby
for me I need grandma helping with the
kids many of them would love to be doing
that providing that moral support that
guidance for many families where
everybody's got to work and childcare
isn't enough and I know moms when kids
aren't in the right place and you
mentally don't know that your kid is in
a good place you can't work you can't
focus so we need our grandparents whole
and healthy and strong not struggling to
pay their own bills like many of them
are so that they can help with the next
generation but see that is now where we
are in America right now so this is
where we are in 2008 and I could go on I
haven't even talked about the
environment
but I don't want to bring you down what
Barack understands and why I am here on
his behalf is that Barack knows that our
greatest challenge is not that we are
suffering from a deficit of resources we
are still one of the wealthiest nations
on the planet still with our economic
ups and downs and it's not that we are
suffering from a deficit of policies and
plans because we know the answers to
many of these issues we know what we're
supposed to do if you take education we
know what good public schools look like
because there are thousands of them all
across this country thousands of
outstanding public schools the problem
is they're too few everybody is
finagling to get their kid into that
decent school they're putting grandma's
address down calling the congressman
standing in line we know many of you
went to that one good school the problem
isn't that we don't know what it looks
like what baraka understands is that we
are suffering from a deficit of empathy
now see that sounds simple and some
people think that all the answers are
complex they require some mathematical
equation some big long ten point plan
what Barack gets is that we have lost
the understanding that we have a mutual
stake in one another that we have an
obligation to sacrifice and compromise
for one another that we cannot live in a
nation where some people have the whole
pie and many people don't even get a
crumb that cannot be sustainable Barack
knows that we have to be at a place
where we understand that we have to
compromise and sacrifice for one another
that's how the society will thrive but
see we've been told just the opposite by
our leaders we've been told don't worry
about anybody else just take care of
your own little plot of land
your kids have a good education don't
worry about anybody else's if you've got
a job don't worry about anybody else you
got healthcare you're good others will
pull themselves up by their own
bootstraps that's what we've been told
we're a nation at war right now we're
the only people who are sacrificing on a
daily basis are the soldiers and their
families our leadership has told us
don't worry about it the rest of y'all
just keep shopping and it's not that we
wouldn't sacrifice Avast as a nation so
we're at a point in time when we are
suffering from a deficit of inspiration
and I know in my heart that the only
person in this race who gets it and who
can re-energize and reinvigorate this
democracy is my husband Barack Obama
but it is important it's important for
people to understand why I say that
because I know there are pit still be
we're down in the polls here in
Pennsylvania we are behind that means
that there are people out there who
don't quite believe that Barack Obama
has what it takes and I'm his wife so
what do I know I'm a little biased but
let me tell you why I say this because I
am NOT crazy I wouldn't be here if I
didn't think that Barack was a person
that we needed right now and why I say
this is because of character again it
sounds so simple but character matters
to me and I am looking for a different
kind of leader a leader who can touch
our souls in a way that we haven't felt
in a while because our souls are broken
and character is critical so who's
Barack Obama and why do I think his
character is so important see my father
told me that you measure the character
of an individual not by what they do
when the lights are shining and the
cameras on I don't care what you did
after you decided you wanted to be
President what were you doing in the
shadows when nobody was looking see this
is where Barack Obama is different trust
me on this Barack has been gaining
experiences in the shadows that his
opponents will say don't count just like
all that money he's raised and those
wins he racked up but let me tell you
who Barack is because I think it's
critical see Barack is a product of a
single parent teenage mother he didn't
have it easy he grew up in Hawaii better
weather
but that's about it let's imagine a 18
year old white woman raising a black kid
in the 60s now you know she was a
dreamer and because of her dreaming his
mother was able to envision a life for
herself that many young girls from
Kansas could not she saw herself
traveling the world going to places like
Indonesia and studying women's issues
helping folks in other countries so
because of her naivete sometimes Barack
and his family lived on food stamps but
he also got to see the world in a way
that many Americans do not and I just
say imagine a president of the United
States who understands and respects
other cultures without fear imagine a
president of the United States who
understands how this great nation can
impact small villages across oceans not
because he's received a policy briefing
from a set of Washington insiders but
because he's lived in those villages
he's got a grandmother living in one of
those villages in tsaia in Kenya imagine
the perspective that we would have on
foreign relations and policies that
comes from just how he's lived his life
there's no other candidate in this race
who would bring that no one and yes he's
had this exotic interesting background
but he was also raised by his maternal
grandparents tootin Gramps they were
from Kansas they were not dreamers they
were folks with their feet firmly
planted in the ground see his
grandparents were like my parents they
were the ones who sacrificed everything
so that his family could have a little
bit more they were the ones who got up
and went to jobs they didn't care about
and when you see people you love
sacrificing for you every day like we
did
you know you're blessed and what you
understand is that you live by a certain
set of values you live your life that
way we learned in our household basic
things like your word is your bond the
truth and honesty count for everything
that you say what you mean that you
don't feel entitled to anything in life
when you're working class kid you don't
expect anything you know you have to
work harder be smarter be tougher and
that's the way it is you're taught that
you treat other people with respect and
dignity even if you don't know them and
especially if you don't always agree
with them because what we learned is
that you never know who you're going to
need to sit down with and work with so
you don't leave your opponents with
nowhere to go because if you're going to
work towards solutions you've got to
build trust that's who Barack is and
he's been a young man I want young
people to understand this who has been
trying to live those values this has
been a young man who has lived every
single minute of his life worrying about
how to demonstrate the principle that to
whom much is given much is expected
imagine a president of the United States
who approaches life from that but Barack
every chance he has had to make a
decision he has illustrated his values
and it started when he left college as
Theresa said he could have gone to Wall
Street make a lot of money but what does
he do becomes a community organizer
working in some of the toughest
neighborhoods in the south side of
Chicago working in the shadows nobody
was watching him then nobody was
counting what he was doing but let me
tell you what he was doing he was
working for people who had a reason to
give up hope folks who lived in
communities much like the ones in the
state
steel mills had gone out of business
folks were unemployed living in
brownfields no jobs unsafe streets no
schools Barack work for years working
mainly with grandparents raising
grandchildren single mothers trying to
hold it together spend years busting
people down to City Hall to help them
find their voice and advocate for change
to find their power you tell me anybody
else in this race whose brings that kind
of experience to the race there is no
one else who has made those choices in
life but Barack has and it doesn't stop
there Barak's a lawyer I'm a lawyer
everybody we know is a lawyer because
that's the only way you can pay off your
student loans but Barack is a lawyer
that could have made millions Barack was
the first african-american president of
the Harvard Law Review if you want to
talk about some bar setting if you want
to talk about sheer intellectual
academic achievement there are many
lawyers in this race there are none who
have done that none and when you would
become the editor of the law review of
the best school in the world you can
write your ticket anywhere but what is
Barack do what was the choice that he
made when nobody was looking he said I'm
going to go back to Chicago teach
constitutional law work for a civil
rights firm why because to whom much is
given much is expected and when you're
given the gift of advocacy you don't
sell it to the highest bidder as Barack
believes you work for the least of these
so Barack worked for years on issues of
housing fairness employment
discrimination voting rights these are
the kind of experiences he was gaining
when nobody was looking experiences that
his opponents will say somehow don't
count but it doesn't stop there Barack
has more legislative experience than his
opponent does
mark has been in the state Senate for
eight years before coming to the US
Senate his opponent hasn't done that and
it's not just any state so when people
say well is Barack tough enough to
handle the Republicans they'll put that
down maybe he's not tough enough I'm
like do you know where we live we live
in Chicago Illinois politics it's some
of the meanest toughest politics every
trick that has been played they taught
it there but what did barack do his
approach to politics was let me not
become of it let me rise above it and
his view was that if you are brought to
politics by regular folks then you can
try some things out you can take some
risks so he said let me try some stuff
out let me see what happens if I
approach politics with my values but
tell the truth if I work hard if I
develop trust with people I don't agree
with what if I listen and build
relationships with people who I don't
know people I don't always understand
what if I keep an open mind what if I
work harder and faster and smarter can I
get something done in Illinois one of
the most divided political state
legislators in the nation let me tell
you what Barack Obama was able to do in
his eight years span health care for
kids in our state passed an earned
income tax credit for working folks help
reform ethics in a state that hadn't
seen ethics reform in more than 25 years
help mend a broken death penalty system
that sent dozens of innocent men to
death row help to ensure that welfare
mothers being put off the rolls had
access to childcare these were just some
of the things that Barack was able to do
at a time when he was in the minority
most of the time so I just say imagine a
president of the United States who has a
proven track record of working in a
tough political climate in a divided
house
and making stuff happen at a time when
we need that kind of leadership there is
no one else in this race who has done
that no one and if we need to know what
folks will do in times of crisis we've
got evidence of that we've got this war
that we're in if we want to know who
these folks are and what they will do
when times are tough let's look at what
i call exhibit a the war in iraq that
was a situation where we had a whole lot
of folks with years of Washington
experience all coming together and
looking at the same facts and
information and see that was a popular
war at the time because we were afraid
and we were mad and we liked tough talk
that made us feel secure and we had a
lot of folks saying we need to fight
this war and very few people had the
guts and the wisdom to stand up and say
no to what was then a popular war the
only person in this race who stood up
when it wasn't convenient for him was
Barack Obama
but remember that bar I was telling you
about well is there again because his
opponent said well his speaking out
doesn't count because he wasn't in the
US Senate at the time when he spoke out
so it doesn't count well let me tell you
where Barack was just to put it in
perspective Barack was not in the US
Senate at the time that he spoke out
because he was trying to get to the US
Senate Barack was in the midst of his
own tough 7-way US Senate primary ways
and it was a race that he wasn't
supposed to win cuz you know what they
were saying about him back then I was
there they said he was too young they
said he was too inexperienced they said
he couldn't raise the money yes they did
they said there was no way he could
build a political organization to
outmatch an Illinois dynasty that was
running they said he was too black and
then they said he wasn't black enough
and when all of that didn't work you
know what they said they went to their
old go to fear bomb and they said his
name watch out for his name I kid you
not I was there they said there was no
way that folks in downstate Illinois
would vote for a man named Barack Obama
fear the name because it's different
they're banking on fear so when you see
Barack getting those mud slings Adam and
he doesn't seem to get all frustrated
it's not that he's crazy it's just that
he's heard it all before there was
nothing new going on
what rock has learned in his political
career is that the American people are
hungry for the truth and they can handle
it but he also knows that we are at a
time politically where when power is
confronted with real change sometimes
they will say anything to stop it so the
question in this race Pennsylvania is
not whether Barack Obama is ready that
is just not the question Barack will be
one of the most dynamic leaders that we
have seen in a long time and the thing
that I want to remind you is that
everybody in this party knows that you
know why I say that because see before
he was running right after that
wonderful speech at the convention
everyone wanted a piece of hope it
wasn't naive in Barack spent the entire
fall traveling around campaigning and
raising money for every single
Democratic race every single person
wanted him on stage with them for a
little piece of hope there wasn't
anything naive about it the problem came
when Barack said you know what I'm
standing back here but maybe I could run
this and that's when folks said whoa
little little buckaroo not so fast the
question for us in this race is what are
we ready for that has always been the
question for me I was curious about what
happens to this nation when they are
confronted with the kind of leaders they
say they want what happens when you get
a decent candidate who is honest works
hard has experience can build an
organization can unite people can
inspire people when he looks you in the
face what do we do do we hold on to that
fear see because that fear sometimes
gives us comfort we're so used to it and
sometimes we like our isolation and
division because it gives us an excuse
not to do anything but what Barack Obama
is asking you he is saying don't count
on me count on yourselves
the kind of change that Barack is
talking about because people say change
to what this is the change that puts the
power of democracy back in your hands
and the question is are you ready to
take it but Barack says you cannot go
back to your lives as normal you can't
be complacent anymore you can't not vote
you can't use fear as an excuse you
can't stay divided and isolated from
your neighbors you have to communicate
you have to organize in your own
neighborhoods in your own schools in
your own churches and synagogues you
cannot turn the TV off and go back to
business as usual so Barack is saying
don't vote me in because you think that
that's it you vote Barack in because you
were now ready to own this
and if that's the kind of change that
you're looking for then there is nobody
else in this race other than Barack who
you should be thinking about but change
this kind of change doesn't come easy we
are going to need Pennsylvania because
in this ever-shifting moving bar barack
obama will always be the underdog no
matter how much money he raises no
matter how many wins he pulls together
no matter how many delegates he
accumulates he is still the underdog
it's the way it works so we need you
Pennsylvania we need you standing with
us we need you praying with us we need
you working voting bringing people out
that's the only way this kind of change
will happen from the bottom up not from
the top down and if you're ready for
that kind of change then he's the man
you want if you don't know what's at
stake then the last thing I'll share
with you is a story I've shared all over
this country after the South Carolina
primary I met this young girl 10 years
old came up to me at a little rally and
a beauty shop in Newberry she walked up
to me pushed through the crowd she said
mrs. Obama I need to tell you something
I was like okay she said do you realize
when your husband becomes the next
president of the United States it would
be historical I said well yeah I said
but what does that mean to you and she
said without missing a beat she said it
means that i can imagine anything for
myself
but then this little girl broke down in
tears right there on the spot she
started crying so hard that it broke my
heart because I started thinking well
what is she crying about couldn't be me
but she couldn't stop seeing as I think
about this little ten-year-old girl I
think you know this little girl gets it
she knows what's at stake in this
election it's 10 year old little girl
she knows how far behind she already is
she knows that she's in schools that are
underfunded that won't prepare her for
anything she's knows she's living in
neighborhoods where most of the people
there don't have jobs she knows that if
she gets sick she won't have access to
any kind of health care she'll sit in an
emergency room until her condition
worsens but see she also knows that she
is so much better than the limited
expectations that this country has of
her she knows in her heart that she has
dreams and dreams is all she has so
don't let anybody tell you that dreaming
and hope don't matter because there are
millions of little kids out there all
they have are their little bitty hopes
and they are counting on us to get this
right they're counting on us to show
them a different side of this nation
different set of possibilities they want
that veil of impossibility snatched off
their heads because it is suffocating
them and how do I know because that
ten-year-old girl was me I am not
supposed to be here every statistic says
that a little black girl from the south
side of Chicago is not supposed to be
here
we still live in a nation for somebody
like me and there are thousands of kids
out here just like me of all races and
locations where the world has told us no
you can't do that had the nerve to think
I could go to Princeton I had counselors
telling me know your test scores aren't
high enough why I applied I got in and
what do you know I graduated with
departmental honors so they were wrong
and then I gotta apply to law school
people tell me don't go for Harvard that
might be a little too tough for you well
I applied I got in i did fine and there
are certainly people who would tell me
that I should not even dream of becoming
the next first lady of the united states
of america but the one thing i want
young people to know out here if you get
nothing else from this race no matter
what the outcome is do not let anybody
set the limits of your dreams no one
because the one thing that I have
learned in my life is that every time I
push past somebody else's limited
expectations of who I should become and
I push my way at the table that others
felt so entitled to but these folks were
supposed to be so much more prepared and
ready every single time I got to the
table and looked around at these folks
there was no magic there they were no
more prepared or ready so all we have in
this world is a little hoping and
dreaming and I want everybody to close
their eyes and just dream a little bit
because it took a lot of dreaming for me
to be here dream of the day that a man
like Barack Obama is standing in front
of the Capitol with his hand on the
Bible taking the oath of office to
become the next president of the United
States and as you close your eyes and
dream imagine what that image alone will
send to the millions of young kids like
me like all of you have been told no
wait don't you can't on that day we show
them a different possibility of one baby
come get me come and who we are and
understand that the world is watching us
as well and there are millions of little
shining stars out there all over the
world who are looking to this nation and
hoping and praying that we can do this
so the question that I have for you
Pennsylvania can we do this
k my god this can't really do this I
unless fired up ready to go we mail dude
thank you
you